il y a soixante ans, la terre a été détectée nous avons gagné
la guerre mais ils ont détruit la moitié de la
planète tout le monde a été évacué avec une équipe de
nettoyage
c'est Mission Control êtes-vous une
équipe efficace nous sommes une équipe efficace
je vous achète deux autour des boissons
quand vous  montez ici deux semaines de plus
Chuck et nous pouvons enfin partir et rejoindre
les autres ne prenez aucun risque
jack est l'un des derniers humains restant sur
terre après une guerre massive qui a rendu la
terre fondamentalement inhabitable à droite nous avons
gagné la guerre non nous avons  pour le quitter, c'est
un col bleu futuriste, en gros,
il répare des drones, il est fasciné par les
reliques du passé, la casquette des Yankees
qu'il trouve lorsqu'il trouve les structures de la
vieille terre, il y a un lien avec cela
qu'il ne peut pas tout à fait expliquer tous les jours  il
descend sur terre pour faire ce travail de juriste
j'essaie de ne pas me faire tuer par l'
ennemi
c'est très dangereux chaque fois que Jack est à
la surface car il est toujours
vulnérable à une embuscade Jack Invicta nos
partenaires elle est en communication  les
systèmes d'officiers sont verts pas de jeu ça a commencé le
garçon en cuir Sam oh tu sais que tu as raison de
travailler sur le fait
qu'ils ont été stationnés ici ensemble
juste les deux au cours des cinq dernières
années
un jour un vaisseau spatial impacte près de l'emplacement de Jack les
drones sont mobiles  gardez votre étiquette en dehors de
cela il y a des humains Jack allez une fois qu'il
vient de se retirer les drones vont gérer
cela c'est une tour négative aucun
survivant jack essaie de comprendre
ce qui se passe ici et dans l'
épave il trouve cette femme Jack comment
vas-tu  connais mon nom
je t'ai regardé Jack moi il est temps
d'apprendre la vérité
tu dois savoir ce qui s'est passé
tout ce qu'il sait
devient inversé les gens pour qui tu travailles
terriblement pour toi jack sait qu'il doit se battre
littéralement le monde est en jeu et  cette
guerre tu n'as pas à mourir
ils n'ont pas à mourir
il est temps pour eux de rentrer à la maison je ne vais pas faire
ça
c'est épique c'est juste une histoire épique forcer l'
humanité à survivre c'est le seul moyen